[Music]
today i'm speaking with ms abigail
schreier
who uh is a writer for the wall street
journal
and the author of a recent book which
was named by the economist as one of the
notable books of 2020
irreversible damage
the transgender craze seducing our
daughters
thanks for agreeing to talk to me today
thank you so much for having me on
so um
why did you write the book i wrote the
book because a
woman wrote to me i and
i had written a piece for the wall
street journal on our transgender
pronoun laws
that we have in new york and california
now that assign
criminal and civil penalties for failing
to use someone's
preferred pronoun and i pointed out that
these laws are straightforwardly
unconstitutional in the united states
and a reader wrote to me she read this
and she said
maybe you'll take up my issue but i'm a
mom my daughter had
no symptoms of gender dysphoria
throughout
you know her growing up but um gender
dysphoria being the severe discomfort
and one's biological sex but she went
off to college he had a lot of mental
health problems
and she went off to college and with a
group of girlfriends they all decided
they were transgender
and she started a course of testosterone
and
i'm you know i've had this problem with
they're now an epidemic
of these young girls who are in a lot of
very real pain
deciding that gender must be their
problem and very quickly obtaining
hormones and surgeries and she told me
that no journalist would take it up she
had
she had written to many journalists and
i tried to find her an investigative
journalist who would write about this or
at least investigate it
and when i was unable to find one i
finally three months later i got back in
touch with her i said all right i'll
i'll look into it
okay so well i can tell you that i uh
have had some trepidation about even
conducting this interview
um yeah well it's because because this
is such a
it's exactly the sort of issue that you
can get pilloried for
and uh i've had a fair bit of that over
the last number of years i mean
i was very unhappy with the canadian
government's
language law provision bill c-16 and
my comments about that caused a whole
sequence of
chain reactions i suppose that changed
my life completely
i was concerned at that time that
the movement let's say the political
movement of the political ideology that
i saw as driving
the language legislation bill c-16
would manifest itself in
psychological trouble for many people
and so i'd read this book
called the discovery of the unconscious
by henri ellenberger and
he talked about psychological uh
contagions
and documented them going back hundreds
of years as a matter of fact and i was
aware that such things
occurred and it struck me as highly
likely that
confusion about gender identity on the
ideological
end and categorical front would
translate itself into
confusion about gender among
adolescents in particular who were just
starting to catalyze their gender
identity
and so you claim in the book that this
is a
epidemic and
one of the things i'm wondering about is
what are
what relevant stats do you have at your
disposal
and why why language like that
well i actually asked a bunch of you
know i interviewed i conducted nearly
200 interviews for the book and i
actually asked a lot of scientists once
i had some numbers
what what do you call this what is it
when you have
we have a hundred year diagnostic
history of gender dysphoria
and it always afflicted boys and men
okay
and now for the very first time the last
decade
there has been a giant surge in a
different population
claiming to be gender dysphoric it has
shifted from from
onset in young boys and to teenage girls
with no childhood history
and it's shifted from men to women so i
asked them when you have a giant
demographic
jump and all of a sudden they are as as
these teenage girls now the leading
demographic so these are girls
who as a population experienced
virtually no gender dysphoria throughout
history
suddenly being the leading demographic i
would ask them what do you call that is
there a scientific term for this
and they would always all say yes
epidemic
i see i see okay so in your
in your wikipedia page which well i read
it this morning and
it struck me as a place where a
battleground was likely taking place
occurring
um in the book it says in the book
schreier
accuses social media of playing a
driving role in girls decisions to
identify as transgender
transgender excuse me based on the
unproven and contentious hypothesis of
rapid onset gender dysphoria
she advocates for withholding gender
affirming medical care for transgender
youth
a fringe position not currently
supported by most reputable medical
organizations now one of the things you
do document in the
book is the rapid move
by organizations like the american
psychological association and the
american psychiatric association
to change the wording that they've used
surrounding the discussion
on gender identity
correct yes that's right they've i mean
they have changed the wording but the
bigger change of course is that they've
gone to an affirmative care
standard which means that they no longer
apply any medical judgment they simply
surrender all judgment
and agree with or affirm the patient
self-diagnosis
right and along with that goes the and
this is part of what made me nervous
about
talking to you and i still probably am
is that
as a medical practitioner as a
psychotherapist
psychotherapists are now bound as far as
i've been able to determine by examining
the law
to adopt precisely this gender affirming
position and i believe that that's the
case in ontario so
i don't do adolescent therapy
but if i had a young adult say 18 or
older
come to me who was expressing
confusion about their gender identity
let's say or
was gingerly testing the waters to
determine if perhaps they were
transgender
i believe that i'm required by law to
to adopt a position that would affirm
that
fundamentally that's right yes sort of
damocles hangs over professionals heads
now
and what it says is you must agree with
the patient self-diagnosis put another
way
it must it suggests that you should
begin with the conclusion
your conclusion must be that this person
has gender dysphoria
and then you can you know go along from
there and start prescribing treatments
that's not how medicine or any other
area of therapy is practice
you don't begin with the conclusion you
investigate it
now you brought up my wikipedia entry oh
sorry you know that go ahead
i mean obviously it's it's the number of
lies that have been put into that i
didn't start the wikipedia entry others
did and there's been
you know back and forth fights with
activists and so so forth to
to rewrite it but of course i i don't
you know advocate any i mean it's not
true i mean so much of what
what what has been said is not true um
first of all the
the affirmative care standard that's
that's the problem and i don't
i don't advocate a particular method of
treating transgender
people i don't even advocate a method of
treating transgender teenagers
all i'm pointing out in the book is that
there are there seems to be a sudden
rise in these teenage girls
who are subject to pure influence in
social media influence
deciding they're transgender and there
are no medical safeguards for these
girls
there's no means right now and no one
determining whether they actually have
the correct diagnosis
before proceeding to treatment that's it
right and so
i guess the the catch 22 here is that if
the statement
um most reputable medical organizations
uh affirm or uh put forward
an affirmative care
requirement then any position that
questions that or objects to it is in
some sense by definition fringe
well it's yes i'm not saying at all that
your position is a fringe position it's
it's a matter i don't see how that can
be avoided under the current
circumstances because
the laws and guidelines are written as
if this is a fate accompli right that we
understand
transgenderism completely and gender
dysphoria and that
you know all the answers are already in
and i don't think that's true for any
psychiatric diagnosis
yes i would just say that it is friends
and so far or it appears fringe because
all the doctors who disagree and there
are many
and they're speaking up all the time are
silenced they are told that they could
lose their license if they don't
immediately affirm
the the adolescent no matter what her
other mental mental health problems are
and immediately go along with
facilitating her transition right you
you talk about uh
the former about the occurrences at the
uh the uh mental health institute in
camh in toronto
yes that's right i mean you had you know
ken zucker you know the
the truly a giant and and the um
in the field of gender dysphoria who
actually oversaw the authoring of the
definition of gender dysphoria he was
fired right
you know let's talk about ken zucker for
for a moment or two so
as you said he occupied a very a
prestigious position
in the world of transgender treatment
and i think was universally regarded as
the most outstanding
and most objective scientist working in
this field
i've spoken to him about it on some
occasions not publicly ever
and he struck me as a dedicated
clinician and researcher and
he advocates advocated for and still
advocates for as far as i know
uh wait and see treatment method based
on the presupposition that
most children with gender dysphoria
who are who events and interest in
transforming their body to that of the
other sex should
be encouraged to wait because if
a waiting technique it's not a technique
even i suppose
if waiting is
with sufficient patience most of the
children who manifest these
concerns desist i think it's 70 to 80
percent of them
uh a certain percentage fairly high come
to the conclusion that they're
gay and it's perhaps the case that
that's driving some of their
early gender dysphoria confusion about
their identity
and zucker was fired from camh and also
pilloried in a variety of newspapers and
other publications as a consequence of
what was essentially his mainstream
stance
now i believe and i haven't followed
this up recently but i believe that
he was engaged in a number of court
battles with the publications that had
um gone after him and i believe that he
won his
legal cases he did they had to apologize
and
he and they settled with him i mean what
they really wronged him
yes i mean that's what happens when
professionals speak
out on this issue and of course when i
say speak out all they're expressing is
concern that there is an over diagnosis
here you're seeing young teenage girls
who do not seem to have typical gender
dysphoria
nonetheless be immediately fast-tracked
towards transition
so i'd asked you a little bit earlier
about numbers do you have any sense of
how how prevalent this is and and also
i'm interested in and i'm sure the
listeners watchers would be as well
rate of increase sure so
um in america it's a little harder to
look at
to come up with these numbers although
i'll tell you the numbers that i do know
okay
it's harder because we don't have
centralized medical care like they do in
britain
in britain where they have centralized
um medical care
they they can tell you that the number
of young women being referred for gender
treatment
has um exploded over four thousand
percent in the last decade
okay in america we don't have
centralized
medical care and um you don't even need
a
a diagnosis of gender dysphoria to start
treatment you can start a course of
testosterone without ever having
received a diagnosis of gender dysphoria
so um so they're a little harder to come
back but here's what i can tell you in
two percent of high school students said
they were transgender so that's two and
a hundred kids
that's an enormous increase over the
what was
historically the rate of gender
dysphoria in the population
which was 0.01 percent so one in
10 000 people went from roughly one in
ten thousand people to two and a hundred
high school students we also know that
between 2016 and 2017
the number of um females requesting
gendered surgery in the united states
quadrupled
so we know these are the exploding rates
and then of course
you know i've interviewed many
therapists and lisa litman of brown
university did her survey
and when you talk to therapists when you
talk to parents you get the same thing
over and over and that is that the
leading demographic asking for gender
transition is teenage girls
teenage girls with no childhood history
of gender dysphoria now
here's here's a contentious issue so
generally speaking
for the the story of long-term gender
dysphoria to be coherent
a girl would have to claim that she'd
always known that she was
in the wrong body that she was a boy and
that that had
been the case ever since early childhood
so maybe she'd be speaking as a teenager
now you make the claim in your book that
girls who go online who are searching
for information about transgender
identity
often encounter coaches who tell them to
falsify their personal narrative and to
claim that they've always
been gender dysphoric despite the fact
that that's not the case
is that is that a reasonable summary of
what you found yes
yes so you can see that it's a complete
diagnostic mess from a therapist
perspective because
and even from a conceptual perspective
because the
people who are on the other side of the
argument than you let's say
are going to claim that the reason that
these rates
have skyrocketed to the point where
they're at now
is because there were always that many
people who had gender dysphoria or who
were transgender
but the weight of public opinion was
held so strongly against them that they
had to stay
in the closet essentially and were
unable to adopt their true identity
and the claim is going to be made as
well that you're
radically exaggerating the
proportion of people who are putting
themselves forward
for transgender transition uh procedures
let's say
who have been coached
right okay so let me respond to a few of
those things first of all i don't think
that's right
i think that i i mean i agree with you
that that's what they would say but
here's i thought about that claim
because um and here's here's what i
would say in response
um if there were this were just as they
say
a natural reversion now that there's
greater societal acceptance of
transgender people that they would say
oh you would expect to see a natural
reversion to what we're seeing now which
they might claim is a normal base rate
of transgender identification in the
population the problem with that is
number one
we're only seeing this sudden spike
among teenage girls where are the women
in their 30s 40s 50s and 60s
who were denied the opportunity to come
out as transgender
they should be coming out too but
they're not can you also
point out i guess the other thing that
you might conclude is that
if the people if the bulk of the
proportion of people
who were claiming a transgender identity
in the past were male
then release of the social strictures on
identification should have produced an
explosion in males
it's not easy to figure out why there is
an explosion in females
okay so that leads us to another
extremely troublesome
topic which is why the explosion in
teenage females now you do attempt to
explain that in your book and so maybe
you could outline for the listeners
exactly what
what your conclusions were sure
teenagers teenage girls are famous for
for this for falling for every hysteria
right we know that the way young women
and there are psychologists who've done
wonderful work in this area amanda rose
is one of the university of missouri uh
who i interviewed
um teenage girls tend to spread
these psychic epidemics because they are
very their modes of friendship
involve co-rumination taking on their
friends pain
they like to rehash their own pain and
they like to take on their friends pain
and they are even willing to suspend
reality
in order to sort of get on the team of
their friend
okay so i'm being a real son of a [ __ ]
in this interview to some degree because
um like i've been trying to think up all
the objections i possibly could to your
perspective because it's so contentious
and so i'm going to put forward things
that i'm
i'm thinking about that are critiques
and
it's not that i'm believing them but
they need to be brought forward so
a skeptic might say that you are relying
on
stereotypes of feminine behavior
in adolescence to justify your claim
that
it's girls that are susceptible to a
kind of hysteria
and that that's an outdated that's an
outdated and sexist
i suppose hypothesis
no i'm not relying on stereotypes at all
i'm relying on evidence
if you look at the anorexia it afflicts
one population if you look at bulimia it
afflicts one population and it grows and
it spreads among
friend groups just as this does it's
young women
encouraging them each other in self-harm
this is and
if you look at cutting same thing and we
know we've
clinicians have known for years that you
cannot house anorexics together in a
hospital ward without being very careful
because they will encourage each other
to learn lose more and more weight
we know that women right and you see
that online with regards to anorexia
right with the proanocytes and the
pro-bulimia sites
right it wasn't men who came up with
thin sporation now i inspiration right
inspiration to lose more and more weight
it was young women now
of course men get involved in all kinds
of you know bad behavior and encouraging
each other in all kinds of bad behavior
but this this kind of so you know um
socially spread self-harm has proven
over and over to be endemic to young
women
you can't group anti-social males
together when they're teenagers because
they get worse
so that's that that's well known and in
fact if you take antisocial boys and you
put them with pro-social boys
the pro-social boys become more
anti-social the anti-social boys don't
get better
and that was discovered back in the
1930s in the summerville study the
the uh detrimental consequences of of
grouping anti-social boys together it
was the um
very large-scale study that was designed
to
uh in principle to reduce the risk of
children boys at risk for developing
criminal behavior and alcoholism and so
forth was one of the first longitudinal
studies
um it was a complete failure in that the
treatment group who were subject to all
sorts of benevolent
at least in principle benevolent
interventions did much worse than the
control group and
after much painstaking analysis and and
and
heart-rending doubt the study's authors
concluded that
housing the children together in the
summer camps they had put out for them
to get them out of the
inner city was actually the cause of
their increased
pathology in adulthood so it does happen
among males
now tumbler is also something that you
discuss
as a new mode of perhaps a new medium of
social contagion and as far as i'm
as far as i know that's also a social
media
forum that's essentially female
dominated is that correct
um i believe it is um still but though i
have not
you know up to date on the latest you
know of who
looks at tumblr but it always has been
yes predominantly
right so all right here's another
question
um what
made you convinced that you were
qualified
to do this because if i was a critic
again i guess that's the next place that
i would attack right because you're not
a mental health professional
and so it might be asked well
what right do you have to investigate
this even that might be one
question but then also to draw
conclusions
well as you'll as i'm sure you saw if
you you know
when you read my book i didn't draw any
medical conclusions that is i relied
entirely on experts and i
do believe it is a journalist's job to
look into
medical you know phenomena including
epidemics
and so forth and investigate them and
and rely on the medical judgment of
experts and that is precisely what i
have done
this isn't my you know all i did was
investigate a phenomenon
with neither a particular hypothesis in
mind but but just being willing to
listen to a lot of experts
and it was their testimony and their
explanation that i put into the book
do you think that it's do you think that
you were even-handed in your selection
of experts
i mean because one of the ways that you
can bias an outcome obviously if you
have a political agenda
you can buy us an outcome by selecting
experts that
testify in one direction and of course
that the transgender
activists and and perhaps the medical
and psychological and psychiat medical
and psychological associations
themselves might regard
people like ken zucker as experts who
you know would appeal to someone of more
conservative sensibilities perhaps
well sorry i'm not i think what you're
saying is did i bias it by only looking
at certain kind of experts
will i say no i didn't if you read the
book i
interviewed experts of all persuasions
but but but more importantly
there are literally thousands i believe
certainly hundreds of books celebrating
immediate medical transition
for teenagers there is precisely one
book that did an investigation
of the risks and benefits and concerns
that that that might be had around the
medicalization of teenage
girls that's it one one book and and the
question is
so so do all these experts have a voice
of course
um i don't claim to have done and
conducted my own
scientific study all i did was show a
willingness to speak to the experts who
are very very concerned about what's
going on here
okay so so let's let's dig even the
layer deeper i suppose
is um why
the the claim that you just made for
example that there is
a very large literature
supporting the idea of medical
transition
and very small literature criticizing it
is striking i don't understand it
what's going on like what's driving this
why is it that the the medical
associations and the psychological
associations have rushed so
precipitously into
gender identity affirmation when the
cost
of it when it's taken to its logical
conclusion
is extraordinarily invasive surgical
modification
which carries substantive risk and which
i think it's
of which i think it's fair to say has
disputable benefits
what why is this happening
well there are a number of reasons it's
happening but if you're asking why
um more medical you know more doctors
and therapists aren't speaking out i
think the answer is because if even
jordan peterson
is a is concerned about having this
interview with me
and with with all of your courage and
all the stances you've taken
imagine what far less courageous doctors
are willing to say
it still strikes me it still strikes me
as
as remarkable that this change has
occurred over such a short period of
time i mean
one of the things you do in the book and
maybe you can you can talk about this
um is document the
the the nature of the treatment the the
medical treatment
for gender dysphoria when the treatment
is
gender transition so you you talk about
the use of testosterone and its subsidy
on university campuses and then you talk
about the more
invasive surgical transformations
double mastectomies phalloplasty and and
which is the creation of a new penis
if you use that word loosely um
these are very
these are not minor procedures including
the use of testosterone
and it's remarkable to me
given that how fast these guidelines for
treatment have changed
well i i think you're right the medical
the the activists have been very
aggressive and very effective here in
the medical accrediting institutions but
i think that all of
at root of all of these changes is a
series of polite
lies that we were um that we swallowed
unfortunately in the public sphere so in
the last week for instance the
california insurance commissioner
has has said that for the purposes
of insurance in california that
breast surgery top surgery double
mastectomy on healthy breasts for even
teenage girls
needs to be regarded no longer as
cosmetic but something that corrects
abnormal
structures because if you've accepted
the lie
that a a young woman who says she's a
boy truly is a boy
then healthy breasts become abnormal
structures
this is the corruption of language so
you must remove them
regardless of her age yeah well language
tends to be associated with action and
it was the corruption of language that i
objected to
you know four years ago because it has
consequences now
you know you made the strongest
statement so far i would say that you
made in our interview
which is the lie that an adolescent girl
who thinks she is a boy truly is a boy
and i suppose it's language like that
that gets you in trouble to the degree
that you get into trouble
because that's a pretty strong statement
the
gender theorists who are driving this
movement i would say put forth the
proposition that
first of all that an individual
always knows what gender they are
even if that changes from day to day
there isn't an authority outside the
individual themselves that can
opine on gender identity
that's that's part of the philosophy
that that drives the
gender affirmation movement i would say
correct right that's part of the
philosophy but unfortunately there's no
biological or empirical or
or means of verifying that we have no
means
of establishing that a girl who believes
she is a boy
is truly a boy well it's more it's more
of a definition than anything else right
it's a place to start it's an
axiom the axiom is that the only
person who can offer an informed opinion
about the g about their gender is the
person themselves no medical
professionals no parents no loved ones
no one else only the individual and
that's even the case if it
changes from day to day or hour to hour
right exactly you could begin with a
conclusion
okay and then then the other
claim and this is the one that that i
have difficulty with logically is that
a girl who thinks she is a boy
is in fact a boy trapped in a girl's
body
which seems to me and that that's been
the case ever since birth
and it seems to me that this is a form
of the biological essentialism
that the gender theorists typically
decry proposing as they typically do
that gender is a social construct
now it isn't obvious to me how gender
can be a social construct
and be something immutable
from birth that's only known to an
individual themselves which sounds a lot
more like a biological explanation to me
so right
right i mean i interviewed affirmative
therapists and i would say to them and
they would say well some kids are gender
fluid
and i would say to them well then how
can you recommend
rever you know top surgery on a young
woman who's
who maybe turn out to be gender fluid
meaning she decides
at some point she isn't she was wrong
she isn't a boy she's a girl
and and um you know this response was
essentially well only she can know her
truth
i mean we are we are we're this is not
medicine any longer it's closer to
witchcraft
so
let me let me let me start at the
beginning
and outline the hypothesis of the book
so over the last
five years there's been a tremendous
transformation in the language and the
conceptualization that's been applied by
medical associations in relationship to
gender
and gender is being defined as
something that's a personal choice
essentially
and
that personal choice has been extended
to the um
to the domain of physiological
transformation
and medical professionals have been
required
are now required to accede to any
requests for physiological
transformation on the part of their
clients or patients as a consequence of
the mandates of their
professional organizations and the
consequence of that has been
a shift in the transgender phenomenon
from a tiny percentage of
primarily males to a 1 in
50 percentage of primarily adolescent
females
many of whom are undergoing the
full physiological or many of whom are
undergoing at least part of the
physiological transformation process
that sums it up essentially i believe
i'm not sure i totally followed that but
i think so okay
well um i probably should have asked you
this at the beginning of the interview
but the basics
i was trying to outline the basic
argument that you were making
right the basic argument that i'm making
is that girls
are is that a lot a large population of
teenage girls who probably do not have
gender dysphoria they certainly have an
atypical form
of gender dysphoria are able to um
quickly obtain hormones and surgeries
they're they're very much you know
they're acting under so you know social
media influence and peer influence we
have numbers on that
certainly not my studies but others have
done studies on this
and they're acting under the influence
of peer influence in social media
influence
they are quickly obtaining hormones and
surgeries and there is virtually
no over medical oversight of this
process
that's the thesis of the book right and
so so the alternating hypothesis are
either that there's been an explosion
in um transgender identifying
individuals because the social
structures have been
taken off the diagnosis or that this is
a
form of psychological contagion
right i i don't i don't think it's the
former i started to explain why
one of the reasons i said is you would
expect you know
a large you know rise in transgender
identification across
populations it wouldn't just be teenage
girls you would see women in their 40s
50s and 60s
you would see more men you know coming
out as transgender um in
incomparable rates but but not only that
you're seeing among this population
we we know that rates of suicide and
depression are rising
as social acceptance um of of gender
dysphoria is going or transgender
identification
is going up but but we would have
predicted
that those things going down with social
acceptance instead
it seems to be you know coincident and
comorbid
with teenage girls mental health crisis
in which we're seeing very very high
rates of um anxiety and depression
i have to think about i have to think
for a minute herein
i want to go back to why this is
happening
so there's been a political arguably
no i won't i won't say that there's been
a transformation
in the way that transgender identity is
conceptualized and treated in the last
five years
what's
what's motivating the people who are who
have been
behind this transformation what's in it
for them
well i think that there are you know
people who are
there there are a number of things there
is a strong ideological
and and um financial
commitments and incentives for certain
people to insist
that that that transition on demand
regardless of
age context or other mental health
problems
be always immediately facilitated
right well it seems like that's it's
that becomes necessary to prove
something it seems to me and that's what
i'm i know
that's what i'm trying to get at is that
it's necessary to set up the medical
system so that
gender dysphoric transgender identifying
teenagers have access to the full
arsenal of medical transformation and
that
helps demonstrate that some other axiom
is true what what is that
is that is it the is the axiom that
gender is in fact
socially constructed
do you see what i mean is that there's
you said there's an ideological reason
what i'm trying to do is to specify that
reason i'd like to understand that
reason
i i don't know know that there is a
larger sociological or
ideological goal i think they are
ideologically
motivated so in other words they have
these commitments but i don't think that
they're trying to prove
something um you know except in the way
that i suppose that they're that they
are saviors
of some kind um you know
look well that would be that would
certainly be something to
that would be motivating to prove i mean
if you notice the doctors who are
pushing this
very often that we what we we're
certainly seeing in the united states
is a young generation of doctors and and
therapists
who are activists firsts and doctors or
second we're seeing this across society
um in all kinds of
you know professions their their
ideological commitments
precede their their um professional
investigation they begin with their
conclusions
yeah well the ideological commitment is
that i this is what i i
ca i can't wrap my head around it
because the ideological commitment
if it's that gender is socially
malleable or a social construct which
seems to be
that seems to be a fundamental axiom
that drives this kind of ideology
i can't see how that can live side
beside side by side
the proposition that the girl who's
trapped in a boy's body has an immutably
male identity
well i think a lot of them yeah a lot of
them just insist on the immutability the
problem is we know that's not true
well except that they also insist on
gender fluidity
right but they also insist on gender to
fluidity i mean i could
i could i could answer your question
this way what is non-binary
because right now in the in the united
states and throughout the west certainly
true in canada
you can get your breasts removed not if
you say you're transgender you don't
even have to say you're transgender but
if a young woman 16 or
up says she is non-binary um that's
enough to allow her without a therapist
note to get her breasts removed
now we how do we know that a non-binary
person has no breasts
i know that a man has no woman's breasts
how do we know that a non-binary person
has no breasts well that's what we know
see that's that's that's a that's a very
good illustration
i would say of the mystery that i'm
trying to nail down
is that your claim is that
breasts or no breasts it's all the same
to the non-binary identity
but that isn't the way it plays out the
way it plays out is that
there's the breast removal proceeds
forthwith
and so that's not i don't i don't
understand that
um well there are no diagnostic markers
at
all or evidence of a non-binary identity
except the say so of
course part of part of it's a matter of
definition now one of the things that
you do in your book
i thought this was quite interesting is
make the claim that when gender theory
is taught in schools
the classic binary genders are presented
in a very
stereotyped manner very stereotyped
very unidimensional unidimensional
stereotype manner
and then any personal deviation from
that stereotype
is regarded as evidence for a non-binary
identity
and so so that's a matter of definition
in some sense right because
you could say that the only genuine
genders
and this would be the redefinition of
the word gender in some sense
the only binary genders are the
stereotypes
and if you are deviant from those
stereotypes on any of the multiple
dimensions
along which they're defined then you are
in fact another gender
you can you can you could you can set up
a definitional structure
in that way and have it be coherent
the the question is what are the
consequences of that
so the consequences is a lot of
confusion for young people trying to
sort these things at
who they are um out at a time when
that's typically done in adolescence i
mean
right do you think these can you
distinguish that from
freedom you know because if i was going
to take the perspective that was
opposite to that i would say no no
what you're doing by deconstructing the
concept of gender itself is allowing
adolescents
much more freedom and exploration of
their identities during a critical
period than would otherwise be the case
now i would temperamentally tend to side
with the confusion hypothesis
i think it's a catastrophe to confuse
adolescents with regards to their
gender identity just when they're
attempting to catalyze that identity
right at the same time that
hormonal transformations are at their
peak and they're undergoing a profound
transformation in self to offer them
a plethora an infinite plethora of ways
to be
none of which have been tested in some
sense in the world
seems to me a recipe for disaster but
does it look like freedom no it doesn't
look like freedom
and i'll tell you why because these
girls are miserable just look at the
number of
of young women on youtube who regret
their transitions already
um they they they they adopt behaviors
after deciding online on some social
media site that their true identity is
is is non-binary oh no wait it's
two-spirit now i'm a two-spirit oh no
wait i'm agender
once they go through these they they
leave lives i mean if you
you know if you talk to them talk to
their parents they are when when i
i wouldn't if these young women were
flourishing i wouldn't have
written the book that's that's not a sad
story they're flourishing
but instead they're cutting off their
parents they're dropping out of school
they have no meaningful employment they
all their friends are only transgender
they hate all cis people
you see patterns that are desperately
unhealthy well
it seems to me you know and maybe this
is a consequence
of not taking the idea of a social role
with sufficient
um seriousness is that
there's a lot more to identity than
your personal feeling
identity is something that's negotiated
in the social community and
an identity is actually a tool that you
use to adapt
so that if you have an identity that
functions we could say
you managed to find a long-term stable
mate
you managed to have children at some
point in your life
you managed to have gainful employment
so that you can support yourself and
maybe in a meaningful and productive
manner you were able to use
your own time outside of work and social
obligations in a manner that's
meaningful to you
you regulate your use of drugs and
alcohol so that you don't
fall by the wayside in in that manner
so what it means is that an identity is
partly who you think you are but it's
also partly the manner in which you
interact with other people and if that
identity is going to be
um useful let's say
if that identity is going to be valid it
has to provide you with a mode of being
in the world
and part of the problem with this
multiplication of gender identities is
that
it's not obvious how you can manifest
them in the world without
transforming the entire world which
isn't going to happen in your lifetime
and so that's
see and maybe that touches on to some
degree touches on
what it is that's driving this is that
it's some
deep desire for a radical social
transformation so that
anything goes and some what would you
call
it's it's pushing look everybody feels
to some degree the restrictive nature of
social roles
you know i just said that you have to
adopt an identity so that you can get by
in the world but that doesn't mean that
there isn't a fair bit of your
individuality that's squashed and
crushed
as you adopt that identity and and
become in some way like everybody else
and maybe this is a rebellion at least
in part against that notion of
having to become like everyone else the
unfortunate reality is though
that if you don't there's no place for
you
that i i think that's right i mean the
young women who do
you know these are overwhelmingly and
you look at lisa littman's study and
uh you know the oh the number of women
were
and i've seen you know my own interviews
the these women are overwhelmingly white
middle and upper
middle upper middle class and they they
have no
um victim status they have no easy
victim status and they need one they
need one to get by socially
um they aren't a minority in any sense
but
this is the one status they can choose
see they can't always choose to be gay
you know but they can choose to be trans
no one no one knows better than they do
who their gender is as
is the saying goes so so no one can
question them the moment they say
they're too spirit or trans
well then another theme i would say that
emerges from your book is the
increasing social inacceptability
among adolescents of what would have
been
more normative gender identities
like these these girls
that that the um the generation that
you're describing
it was also is also characterized
according to the research that you did
in
your book and research that's been put
forward
elsewhere by a dearth of intimate
relationships
and so it also seems to be right one of
the things you pointed out was i think
it was i don't remember if you talked
about 16 year old girls or 18 year old
girls but
in the year and a half preceding being
asked the question
half of them hadn't had anything that
resembled
any aspect of an intimate couple's
relationship
that seems to be a radical
transformation so is it also partly that
the more
traditional gender roles aren't working
no i i don't i don't know that they
aren't working i i don't know that
they've ever explored them
look these are young very sheltered
young girls
these are the generation that grew up
with helicopter parents and they
have had barely ever had a kiss they've
never held hands
they spent all their time on their phone
they don't know their own bodies and
their own desires
and they don't know and they haven't
experienced romantic relationships with
each other
so they don't know who they are and they
don't know what they want and instead
they turn to the internet to answer all
their questions
what do you suppose has happened i mean
i i
thought that the statistic that you put
forward about
the lack of intimate relationship
because you those were population-based
statistics if i remember correctly right
you weren't looking at a small minority
of teenage girls who who
were on the road to transition this was
that generation
right why aren't these teenagers dating
and and and interacting with members of
the opposite sex like they were only
15 years ago or 20 years ago what's
failed
like do you see this as a as a
consequence of technological
transformation
there are many many many things at play
one they're with mom all the time
these kids report being at mom with mom
they don't they get a driver's license
until much later they don't spend time
with each other they're with mom all the
time
um even they talk to her all day they
text her all you know
in a constant basis um so they don't
have freedom to be alone with each other
and then when they are alone with each
other rather than being
intimate and sharing things and
exploring each other and you know even
just
in in a verbal way or in any way um
they're on their phones
um so that's at play there's also
pornography
i mean we've seen you know there's been
studies that show where there's
statistics that show that young men
are experiencing erectile dysfunction
young men men under 30
at rates we've never seen before because
of online porn
so basically the one thing that biology
evolved that men were
evolved to be able to do social media or
online porn content has made it hard for
them to do
you know difficult for them to achieve
we've never seen you know these kinds of
um rewiring of human sexuality that's
going on because
people aren't spending time with each
other in person there's these young
people are spending time
online a lot yeah okay so so part of
you you do see at least part of this
transformation as being driven by
by the phone by the by the constant by
the constant constant electronic
tethering let's say
and part of that tethering is to the
parent and part of that tethering is to
friends but it's
mediated by electronic communication
it's not direct
one-on-one interaction and maybe that's
the case with the boys
yes but the images that girls see online
are just as frightening because they're
seeing
violent porn at very very young ages
women being choked within an
inch of their life this is what young
girls think sex looks like with the
opposite you know
with with the man and they're terrified
of it
um it doesn't look anything to look
forward to instead it looks like
something to run away
well it's never presented with with in
with regards to pornography sexuality is
never
um represented as part of an intimate
relationship
right it's its own thing sex it's not
an integrated part of a loving
relationship which
is what it should be under optimal
circumstances
you don't you don't see that
that doesn't attract widespread
impulsive
um viewing right but it's also violent
and that's the
that and some you're right there's
always been this porn that exists in
playboy and whatever
um divorced from intimate relationships
fine but
what young girls at age 11 younger are
seeing
are violent violent porn that's what
they know of sex and they're seeing it
at a very young age and it's terrifying
okay so let me ask you about that i mean
um
how confident are you in that
proposition i mean uh
you're we're we're trying to determine
why it is that there's a generation of
young women who
are much less likely to engage in dating
intimate relationships of of the classic
teenage style
and it's not like anybody knows the
answer to this because it's such a new
phenomenon
and so are these tentative hypotheses
that you're putting forward or do you
have some
um
how how solid are you in your belief
that these are the fact that you've
correctly identified the factors that
are driving this
well the the core you know thing i look
at in the book
is you know what's going on with why is
there this epidemic the sun explosion
and what are the risks and benefits and
what
why you know are these girls thriving
are they doing well and should we be
concerned and why
okay now the the part of this
observation was to look at the culture
and what was going on in the culture
and observe the fact that young women
are having sex and
intimate relationships at much lower
rates that is not my
research that was done you know by gene
uh by the there are a number of people
who've been doing this um kate julian
had a wonderful article in the atlantic
in which he interviewed many
psychologists about this but it's it's
it's been you know something that many
psychologists have
observed and studied and very unexpected
very unexpected
development right right not exactly it's
not what you'd predict at all
when all the social constraints or many
of the social constraints have been
removed from
every possible form of sexual behavior
the consequence of that has been a
precipitous decline in sexual behavior
among adolescents
and i guess we didn't talk at all about
what the role of the boys might be in
this like are girls not
um dating let's say and engaging in
intimate relationships when they're
teenagers
because of something that's changed with
them or or have the boys stopped
asking um you know it
that that's a good question about
whether so i didn't what i was trying to
say is i didn't look into specifically
or investigate
why there's this you know sudden drop in
sexual activity
or even intimate relationship activity
among teenagers
um so there are things i can surmise
from looking at the culture and writing
about the culture as i do but do i have
studies on this no i don't know i don't
have
you know a a real answer that i've i've
come across
yet well the pornography question's an
open one right because
right that that's a form of
easily accessible gratification with
endless novelty
that's never been you know it's possible
for a young man to see more beautiful
nude women in one afternoon than any
human being that ever lived before 1950
would have seen in his entire life
right and and right and and of such
variety i mean that's right well
novelty is a huge driver of sexual
arousal and
and pleasure and so the and i mean i
also think that's
part of the reason why i don't just
think that there's evidence for this but
it's one of the drivers for the the
proliferation of multiple forms of
pornography is that novelty is a driver
of
sexual arousal and so there's an arms
race online
that consists of a combination of sexual
imagery and novelty and that would drive
the production of
violent videos for example or
anything that's different right is is
going to add an edge
a novelty image especially to a hardened
pornography user
hardened is probably the wrong word
there by the way
right and the problem with this of
course is not that there's so much
pornography i mean online but of course
that
that we're also seeing men be less
inclined to
engage in intimate relationships lesson
able to even
perform i mean these you know because of
it i mean it's the rewiring of
young people so that they're so
incompatible for each other
that's the real sort of disturbing part
if these young
people and this applies to this young
you know group of
of women who suddenly decide they're
transgender if they were
forming families and living good lives
um that's a success story but that's not
the story that's not the story that i
found in my book
right unless you define success as being
allowed to pursue
whatever fragmentary identity occupies
their consciousness at any given time
and you can define it that way right i
mean you're using
and i would use as well i would say more
conservative criteria for what
constitutes a good life you know as a
clinician i
i listed as a clinician it struck me
that
you can assess someone's mental health
with some degree of accuracy by looking
at the success of their embeddedness
within their social community and that's
why i outline
markers of a good life like gainful and
meaningful employment
and education to the to the
to the extent of your intelligence and
the ability to form an intimate
long-term relationship and children and
all these things that seem to make up
the bedrock of life but
again to some degree that's a matter of
definition
right you could object to all of that
and say well no that's a very 1950s or
1970s way of looking at the world and
that's long gone and and now
what we're trying to do is facilitate
people's
the broadest possible range of choices
among people
so that we have a world that's much more
diverse and it's
in its expression of identity it's a
very difficult
argument to contend with i think it's
deeply wrong
i think it's too confusing for people
but
i mean except that they a lot of these
young women their mental health after
the trans identification deteriorated
so they're not able to function look i
have no i
i have interviewed many transgender
adults who are flourishing
they're leading good lives they're in
they're gainfully employed
they are happy they're socially
connected that is
that is not a problem story the reason
that these young girls
are are the subject of my book is
because
they're not flourishing they're not
doing well they're not connected to
friends and family
they're not staying in school do you
think and i don't know the literature on
this
and i guess it's partly because it's so
soon after the phenomena emerged itself
um do you know the literature
on the relationship between mental
health and
movement through the transitioning
process it's tricky a because you point
out
in your book that if you're an anxious
teenage girl or maybe even an anxious
teenage guy and you're given
testosterone
at least in the short term that can do
wonders for your anxiety
and so whether or not mental health
improves might depend
very much on when you measure it so
if you're anxious and your identity is
chaotic and you take testosterone
the immediate consequence of that is
that you're going to be much less
anxious at least and
why wouldn't you think immediately that
that's evidence that there was something
astray with your identity that this
magic hormone fixed
you know time frame is a killer problem
when you're trying to assess mental
health
so what studies are or what data are you
looking at when you
generate the proposition that going down
the medical transition road
isn't producing the positive outcome
that it's hypothetically designed to
produce
well first of all i only say that it's
not producing that outcome
for these teenage girls who i believe
are misdiagnosing
okay so i don't make a claim about
transgender adults who went through
therapy
arrived at this decision as mature
adults and
and are living you know a life as a
transgender person i never make a claim
that that wasn't a good or the right
move for them right well i don't and i
don't know
i don't think that there is a reliable
literature
on the long-term outcome of gender
transition surgery even in those cases
because so so and the phenomena we're
discussing is much newer than that so
the data aren't it's very difficult for
the data to be in yet
so i'm wondering again
why you concluded that it's not working
well there are a number of reasons first
of all you know obviously i used
lisa littman's um study which was the
jumping off point for my book
um brown university public health
researcher who looked into this
you're also seeing clinicians report the
same across the western world
that they're seeing a sudden spike of
gender dysphoria that seems to be pure
motivated or
claimed gender dysphoria that seems to
be pure motivated
and social media motivated okay it's not
an
organic problem and it doesn't look like
traditional gender dysphoria
um you're also seeing numbers of d
transitioners
explode on youtube so if you go to
youtube week to week
the number of d transitioners and you're
right about the timeline by the way
of course that's always going to be
relevant so testosterone does deliver a
high
as you said and it does suppress anxiety
so some women who self-medicated with it
feel great after they've started a
course of testosterone
but very often if you listen to these
transitional accounts i've listened to
many many of them
um um they will report that then then
after that
you know spike their anxiety and
depression came right back
and there's a woman i recently listened
to called waffling willow
she goes by on youtube who did a 12 part
series on my book i i never
met her i didn't know about her until
she did this but she's a d
transitioner did a 12-part session on my
book
in which she said yes this was totally
her experience as a teenager she
transitioned very quickly
and at first she felt great on the
testosterone and then she realized that
and then she had
basically a crash in which all of the
other mental health issues that she had
returned
yeah well that well that's a good
example of the difficulty in
doing longitudinal mental health outcome
studies especially in an uncontrolled
environment their
clinical studies are notoriously
difficult to conduct
and the time frame problem devils
bedevils them
and this is this is a particularly nasty
situation
given that testosterone produces that
initial high
so you can cherry pick your data to some
degree if you look early in the
transition process you might well see an
improvement and then you you can argue
about what
what's contributing to that you know
whether it's just the pharmacological
effect of the testosterone or if it is
actually proof that the
gender identity confusion in question
was real
there's also of course the tavistock
report out of the gender clinic the
largest gender clinic in the united
kingdom
which showed that there was no um mental
health
improvement no improvement in suicidal
ideation
for young women who have been started on
you know puberty blockers and then
cross-sex hormones
so um you know the there we aren't
seeing the improvement that was
supposedly
you know claimed as the the rationale
for starting young
people on these um treatments
yeah i wonder i'm going to go back to
something that we talked about earlier
when
we're trying to pin down what the
motivation for this ideology might be
like the the notion that your identity
is yours alone to determine
strikes me as it's a profound
it's profoundly narcissistic it seems to
me to be predicated on the idea that
you have the right to be master of your
own
master of your own domain master of your
own uh
uh your outcome regardless of
people around you you're the only person
that has to be taken into account
so that would go along with the um
the express claim that you're the only
person that can
determine what your identity is it seems
to me to be a very
infantile and narcissistic wish that
that might be the case
you know that you could decide who you
were and that the world would be forced
to bend around your will
and i can understand that again as i
said because
everybody fights a battle against
society
molding them and destroying their
individuality while they're socialized
it's a it's a there's something there
that's valid to rebel against but
generally speaking as you mature you
start to understand that
you have to negotiate your way through
the world with other people
and that the benefits of being
acceptable to other people
outweigh the costs to your own
narcissistic self-determination
and it's it's the desire to not
have to contend with that
compromise that drives i believe that
drives the insistence that
you are the only person that can
determine your identity
that's right i think that the activists
in this movement have a lot more in
common
with say the black lives matter movement
and others such
um uh you know so-called woke movements
than they do with adult transgender
people when i talk to interview
you know a gente or adults they don't
insist that they were always
girls or always boys they don't ask you
to suspend reality they say look i had
gender dysphoria from the time i was a
child
you know i struggled with it for many
years as an adult i went through therapy
and i realized this was the way to
you know calm my gender dysphoria and
this is how i'm most comfortable
presenting that's not imposing anything
on the world really
but the group of insistent activists
many of whom are not transgender
themselves
but insist that we suspend reality that
medical professionals agree with them
yes you were always a girl or you were
always a boy
this kind of stuff this is an aggressive
ideological movement that really has
nothing to do with
um gender dysphoria per se yeah well i'm
i've been trying to put my finger on
while i was reading your book as well
what it is that's the driving factor and
you know if you look at there's broad
philosophical streams like those that
emerge from the writings of rousseau
that claim that
human beings as individuals are
essentially good and pristine in their
fundamental nature and that
culture its culture that corrupts them
you know it's a very one-sided view
you can take the hobbesian perspective
which is exactly the opposite and say
that well people are
self-interested narcissistic and
malevolent and it's only society that
makes them good and
i would say a balanced viewpoint
emerges if you integrate both of those
views even though they're paradoxical to
some degree
you pay for your socialization and you
benefit and
you sacrifice something of value but you
also gain and that's what you
decide if you're mature if you if you
stay locked in the notion that social
pressure
in and of itself is the perverting force
that
destroys your soul and your psyche then
you're going to be motivated
to push as hard as you can to justify
your claims that
your identity is something that you
yourself determine and that no one has
any right to interfere with that
whatsoever
and maybe if you have to sacrifice
people
in order to justify that claim that's
okay
because the claim is important enough to
you so that
those sacrifices are warranted
you know i got a sense of horror in some
sense from reading your book
especially when you started to describe
the surgery and
so maybe we could walk through that a
little bit let's say that you do decide
to walk down the gender transition road
as an adolescent female
you can look forward to a high that's
generated by testosterone and maybe
that's
something short-term and positive but
what else can you look forward to
well um i i i suppose then the next
what can you look forward to no i'm
being facetious gotcha yes
um well the the so the testosterone
delivers that but it also comes with
risks i don't know if you
want me to talk about those yes i i and
and also the
experience you talk about voice
deepening and hair development and
all of that walk through it what walk
through what happens to a person if they
if they go down this road for the in the
first few months
on testosterone at 10 to 40 times what a
young woman's body would normally
experience
her voice will change and masculinize
that does not seem to go away
um you know her she made she will her
facial features will change
they will round her shoulders will
broaden and it will redistribute fat so
if she's concerned about her fat
all of a sudden in the places women
develop fat belly and and
thighs all of a sudden wow she's lost
weight and she can develop more muscle
the problem is is that a lot of these
changes are permanent
the masculinization of the facial
features and whatnot and also that comes
with very big
risk of cardiac arrest and cardiac risk
seems to be you know much much higher
than a woman would normally experience
even
more than a man would normally
experience it seems um
and you also discussed the effects on um
fertility and
and um sexual threat right so
um there were a vaginal atrophy and
uterine atrophy occur
there can even it can be quite painful
and um
so in some cases making intercourse
impossible if there's enough atrophy
it's quite painful and because of the
increased risk of endometrial cancer
doctors typically recommend at five
years on testosterone
and prophylactic hysterectomy so even
assuming that the
testosterone doesn't impact her
fertility which it may
the hysterectomy certainly will make
that impossible um
so you know those are some of the rest
of testosterone but the biggest risk of
all of course
is that we have no idea all the
long-term effects
of what testosterone at 10 to 40 times
what her body would normally
happen will do to her right and that's a
long-term course of treatment
right because she can't go off it
because if she goes off it at any point
she will go back some of her changes
will revert she'll go back to an
in-between male and female look
so once you start you become a permanent
medical patient
and we just don't know you know we don't
have enough evidence of what
this what will happen you know to these
patient population all the problems they
will incur
in the long term then of course there's
there's double mastectomy which is the
only cosmetic surgery or
considered cosmetic surgery i'm aware of
that you show up without a
mental health professional's note even
as a minor you can have your breasts
removed
um it destroys biological function
obviously it destroys all
capacity for breastfeeding as well as
erotic function
very often and um and and yet
you know it's and you outline some of
the the potential
side effects of that as well um the
i believe monthly engorgement of breast
tissue and leaks and that sort of thing
as a consequence of
only partial removal of the breast
tissue i got that right
right and whether the testosterone is
enough i mean you know if you go off
testosterone your breasts may refill
with
with milk even after they've been
removed you may have some drainage
problems i mean drainage is another side
effect that
often happens very often women are
unhappy with the look they want a second
surgery to repair the look of it
and why are they unhappy with the look
because they're
they're they're chasing an asymptote
they're running after
a horizon the the final look of being a
man which they never which is always a
little bit out of reach
i mean i uh some of the people i
interviewed for the book were forensic
anthropologists because i wanted to know
about skeletons what
you know are there skeletal differences
between men and women
and it turns out there are even the
sloping of the forehead
won't be quite quite right they'll be
smaller they'll have smaller hands
they'll have differently shaped
pelvises no matter what other you know
surgeries they get
there they're they're actually their
femurs will attach differently for
a woman than they do for a man right and
that accounts for the difference in
gait and there's a difference in in
angle of the
forearm connection to the to the upper
arm as well
because of the difference in hip hip to
waist ratio
all these subtle differences between men
and women it's hard enough for a man to
be an ideal man
much less a woman to be transformed into
an ideal man
and if you're an individual who has some
questions about
the acceptability of your physical
appearance then
you can imagine that it's quite likely
that that's going to be maintained as
you make the transition to another
gender
right and there's something else i asked
one of the doctors about because i
started looking at many pictures of the
young women who had received a double
mastectomy and i
i noticed something i said wait a second
look at their hips they have a woman's
hips which become even more
obvious once they've had their breasts
removed so um
you know the doctor said to me that's
right there's a surgery there's another
surgery they can get if they if they're
concerned that their hips are protruding
too much
so you see that there this is not an
easy fix and yet
it's being doled out you know quite
quite casually
right and but and by casually you mean
that
there's no screening in place
essentially to stop women from beginning
this
transformation process and that also you
point out that
so many um medical uh health insurance
schemes
like those provided by universities now
cover
the testosterone certainly but also
the medical procedures themselves to
reduce their costs to a point where
they're much more accessible than they
would be otherwise
that's right i talked to a woman a week
or two ago who
whose daughter suddenly decided she was
trans at university she was at a very
top american university and at
university she not only started a course
of testosterone but she was able to get
her breasts removed
yes well that would be rather shocking
news for any parent to contend with
so let me shift gears for a minute if
you wouldn't mind
what has been the personal consequence
for you of writing this book
i mean i can't imagine hitting a more
active hornet's nest so is it okay that
you wrote it
do you regret writing it and and what's
happened
personally to you because you've written
it
you know it's it's been something of a a
journey um
you know when i started this project it
was so
you know once i started i i was just in
a sort of a constant state of shock and
revelation
and i couldn't really believe this was
happening and it was struck me
the more i investigated it it struck me
as so so
such obvious madness that there would be
no um
you know oversight and no you know
guardians or
or gatekeepers in place that i just kept
thinking
at the end of this everyone's going to
be shocked and
you know this will become a safer
procedure or you know everyone will have
to agree
i didn't write the book for religious
people i didn't write the book for
conservatives
i just wrote it for common sense people
who were interested
in the number of of teenage girls
suddenly coming out as transgender
and i was i couldn't i mean the number i
can't even tell you how many parents
have called me since the book came out
while the book was coming out
um telling me that 20 30 40 of their you
know whatever
very high 15 20 30 of their daughter's
seventh grade class suddenly decided
they were transgender
sometimes at girls schools their boys
weren't even relevant it was at a girls
school or at least they weren't around
um so on the one hand i and then
then of course in the in england the
high court came out
and it came out with a decision that
effectively
um verified everything i had to say in
the book
um they said right that was the case of
the detransitioning girl i mean
i thought i thought five years ago i
thought
or more i thought this will all come to
an end when these
adolescents hit adulthood and start to
bring the lawyers into play for
everything that was done for them let's
say
when they were teenagers and that that
high high court case do you want to just
outline that briefly for
sure a young woman named kiera bell
brought a case against the
she brought a claim against the
tavistock gender clinic
in england in which she said i was
started on these treatments hormone
treatments i was sure i was transgender
i had i started um i you know i i had
never had a childhood history of gender
dysphoria but
as a teenager i was very uncomfortable
in my body and
i decided i was transgender and at 16 i
was started on the course of puberty
blockers and then cross-sex hormones
she eventually went on to have her
breasts removed and she realized as an
as a young woman in her 20s that she was
she had gone down the wrong path that
none of this had made her any happier
and that she wasn't
supposed to be transgender she was a
lesbian
and that was all and she had no and she
was very upset
that nobody had stopped her nobody had
exercised
any judgment it had been a celebration
only zone
from the moment even from medical
professionals and therapists from the
moment
she decided she was transgender and the
court looked at this population of
teenage girls and was horrified
and if you read the decision you know as
i have um and written about it
it's it's it just came out in in
december right right
they said that it's basically you know
young
people under 16 should not be allowed to
be giving informed consent
they can't give meaningful consent to
doing away with their
future fertility their children and
there's in no sense is this informed
consent for
a possibility of a sexual life because
in many cases they may this may lead to
sexual dysfunction
they can't foreclose sexual life a
healthy adult sexual life
and and fertility as as as minors
you know um how many 19 year old
women who claim to not want children
have children in the upcoming decade
i mean i don't know the statistics but i
do know that
a very large number of 19 year old women
that i knew when i was 19 had decided
that they weren't going to have children
and all of the ones that i knew either
eventually had children or were very
unhappy that they didn't
you know by the time they had hit their
mid-30s
and so that's right i mean
we don't know that much about our future
selves and the question is
under what circumstances we should be
allowed to sacrifice them
you know so that that's right and that's
the problem it's not that these girls
are having these feelings but that our
adults are immediately
supplying the irreversible treatments
without any
medical judgment or differential diet
well you also this is part of
what's horrifying about your book we
didn't talk about some of the other
surgical complications for example with
regards to phalloplasty which we might
want to dive into just briefly
because i wasn't aware of the mechanics
of that particular operation let's say
and
it's enough to give you pause i would
say
um in any case uh
well let's do that now why don't why
don't you talk about phthaloplasty and
describe that
sure it begins with the de-sleeving of
the forearm they have to remove the fat
and muscle
from around the forearm that's what's
used as the shaft of the knee
how much is removed oh gosh um
many inches if you see young women
videos you can go online and see
views of women who've had their forearms
de-sleeved it's a
long stretch of the forearm in order to
get enough skin
to form the neophallus um then they have
to transfer
a peripheral artery and
and nerves to that area they have to
graft it obviously it's extremely
difficult work
future surgeries are needed if you
needed to be able to
um first of all just making it
able to um you know have a urine stream
um without infection is extraordinarily
difficult often that you know
complications include
urine that sprays rather than streams um
it's extremely difficult to to achieve
and and and then of course having it
harden
um at all is difficult it requires a
further surgery and
and what does the surgery entail for
that is that inflatables
yes that's right there's some sort of
inflatable um thing put into
what would be like the sort of the
testicle i mean the uh scrotum um the
manufactured scrotum
um so that that to make it inflatable
but it's very hard to get it
hard it's very difficult to get it hard
enough to penetrate for sex
and if you do get penetration what's the
pleasure
that oh are they able to get the same
amount of sexual or the
you know achieve orgasm actually that it
depends on
um i don't know how often they're able
to achieve any kind of sexual orgasm
but i do know that um you know if they
start out
if their their puberty is blocked by
um by you know early on and then they go
to cross-sex hormones and then they have
these operations
um sexual dysfunction and inability to
ever achieve
orgasm is becomes much more likely um
because they never finished their you
know all the tanner stages involved in
you know um making a young person be
able to
eventually achieve orgasm so um there
are a lot of problems and
but the biggest problem with the surgery
i'm told you know i've interviewed a lot
of surgeons and i'm told that
that surgeons who do this very well and
are very skilled at this and very highly
trained in this
can do a pretty impressive phalloplasty
um but the problem of course is these
are big money makers and for hospitals
there's a lot of pressure to do this
surgery
and i keep hearing from surgeons that
the people who are doing these surgeries
are very often
not qualified they're not qualified to
transfer peripheral nerves
each of these micro surgeries involves a
different separate fellowship and they
haven't done those
because the the hospitals are so
desperate to make this extra money that
they're not putting the safe
they're not applying the the traditional
safeguards that they normally would
it doesn't take much imagination for
someone who's undergone surgery or
have have witnessed someone under who
undergone who underwent surgery
to imagine just exactly how complicated
and difficult this is
especially to bring about anything
approximating success
so we didn't finish
our discussion of the impact on you
personally so you said that you were
continually shocked so it was i imagine
somewhat demanding psychologically to do
the research that was necessary to write
the book
but then there's also the consequence of
publishing it and
and the
notoriety or unpopularity that that
might
have produced right so
i i suppose you know i i suppose i would
fall into
disagreeable as my uh personality you
know um
category that i learned from you um
in the sense that you know i'm not
someone who
i you know things lies really bother me
they just bother me on a moral
intuitional level um so i really sort of
wrote this not looking to make friends
but just because
gosh the truth seemed obvious and it was
fairly horrifying and it didn't affect
me personally or my family personally so
if it had i think i would have had
trouble writing it
um i i don't think i would have been
able to women who's who's and
fathers mothers and fathers who've
watched their daughters go through this
are are absolutely
devastated and it's not something i
would have been able to do
if this had been a personal issue but i
wrote the book i thought it was a very
fair treatment
makes you wonder too when yeah when
you're doing analysis of the outcomes of
surgery
if you take into account the effects of
that
on the immediate family members if
that's a valid scientific question
you know what i mean that like you could
say look the only person who's ever
affected
by a surgery is the person upon whom the
surgery is performed
and perhaps that's the case and perhaps
that's a reasonable perspective but
we are embedded in familial structures
and
if if a surgical procedure makes
person a temporarily happy or even maybe
happy over the long run but devastates
five other people
it seems to me that it's at least worth
asking the question of whether that
should be taken into account especially
when you're talking about teenagers
right i i don't think it's that it
devastates the parents because they
they can't stand the thought of having a
transgender
child son or daughter in fact they were
overwhelmingly politically progressive
and supported and they were big they
considered themselves allies
uh long before gay rights was was was
possible you know sorry
gay marriage was possible in america so
illegal in america
so um the it wasn't that it's they were
so miserable and so devastated because
they thought their daughters were so
miserable and likely to
and regretting this already or likely
didn't regret it because they saw the
lives their daughters were leading so
i think while i was writing the book i
just thought this is so obviously
true you know everything there's
everything in the book is true
nobody has pointed to a single factual
error and the book has been
under a tremendous amount of fire now
for six months
so and how have you withstood that
so i think that the hardest thing about
the fire
in in a certain sense is all the
to be honest i you know it's all the
polite
people out there who who won't
even you know who are willing to to to
say oh
you know you're you're effectively provi
well you wrote that provocative book
as if as if they don't they almost don't
seem not to know that it's a
journalist's job to go out and
investigate phenomena especially
cultural ones that seem to be real
i didn't go looking for trouble trouble
is all around us in america today
i mean you know i mentioned the you know
states are lowering the age of medical
consent
across the country so that so that kids
can get
all kinds of surgeries i mean in oregon
the age of medical consent is 15.
so a 15 year old in oregon can get her
breasts removed without her parents
permission
now you don't need to be a religious
person to find that disturbing
or alarming you don't need to be
conservative for sure
but just a thinking person who says gosh
that seems
really young i know i had a lot of crazy
ideas at 15.
you know i'm glad no one would have
given me that option
who do you want to read your book
oh i you know
i mean and the books for anyone to read
but i suppose parents parents um have
been very helped by it
um or they felt you know they felt it
was very useful
clinicians have told me it's very useful
um in in
in just helping them sort of develop a
you know sense that they're not
completely insane when they think this
is a whole lot of
kids suddenly deciding their transgender
out of the blue this can't be right
there's no oversight you know
feeling that they're not alone um but
you know i'm happy for people who are
affirmative therapists to read the book
i mean i'm happy for anyone to read the
book
um you know i unlike those who have
called for my book to be banned and
burned
um i i you know i'm not in favor of
those things they're
you know i i would happily be happy for
anyone to read it and of course i would
never want another book banned or burned
and so you're you remain
pleased with your decision to write it
the truth is i'm not sure i could have
done anything else i mean once i was
aware of what was going on i wrote an
article about it for the wall street
journal
and it's got a huge amount of traction i
mean people were writing to me across
the country even across
the west to say yes this is going on in
their daughter's school yes let me tell
you my story
i mean i'm sure there are people who
could have walked away from that but i
i'm not one of them i thought gosh
there's something worth investigating
here and
how could i just walk away from that and
not look into it
well you know i think that's probably
a reasonable place for us to end what do
you think do you have anything else that
you'd like to say
oh um no i i just uh
thank you very much for having me on and
uh
and um you know a big admirer of yours
and i really appreciate the opportunity
to talk about well i'm
i'm i'm pleased that you were willing to
discuss your book and uh
it's i'm hoping that
many people will read it and think about
what it
and think about it um there's lots to
think about
uh the transgender surgery being part of
that but by no means the
necessarily the larger the largest part
so thank you very much
can i just say one more thing yes just
say one last thing
look the lies have to stop somewhere
i could have walked away from this i'm
not saying it's been fun and i'm not
saying it's been easy since the book
came out there have been plenty of times
when i thought
i really don't know if i have i chose
the right path here
but i have to tell you something the
lies have to stop
somewhere don't they i mean they're just
we're right now we're living through a
blizzard of them and at some point
someone has to say you know a few of us
who are just
you know willing to need to say enough
we
we have to subject this to the same
medical scrutiny
and this is skepticism that we would
subject anything else to
any other medical phenomenon yes well
terrible as objecting to the lies might
be
i suspect that it's not as terrible as
the consequences of letting them
flourish
unchallenged i mean that's right i mean
a lot of young women are getting
badly hurt and at some point somebody
has to be willing to say something
well i i hope i hope that your book
helps
that would be would be
that would be what anyone who was
thinking clearly would hope
thank you
[Music]
you